Professor Mark Saltzman:
So, today I'm going to
continue to talk about
applications of Biomedical
Engineering,
so as sort of a way to bring
together some of the concepts
that we've talked about over the
last several months.
Tuesday, I focused on
applications in cancer.
We thought about how imaging
techniques, how instruments that
deliver radiation,
how molecules and cells could
be used to treat cancer.
Today we're going to--the focus
is going to be on artificial
materials.
Biomaterials,
which are widely used in
medicine now and were produced
largely through the work of
material scientists and chemical
engineers,
and biomedical engineers over
the last 100 years or so.
We'll talk about some of the
difficulties with creating a
material that can be implanted
in the body,
and we'll talk about some of
the applications of those
materials, particularly in
artificial organs,
is where I want to end up for
the day.
These are two pictures from
the text that I present,
just to show you that the idea
of using artificial materials to
replace tissues that are lost
for one reason or another,
is not new.
The one picture here shows a
remarkable discovery from a
mummy that is something like
3,000 years old.
This particular mummy was a
woman who had a toe that was
amputated for some reason.
The toe was replaced by a
synthetic--well not a synthetic,
a natural material,
fashioned to look like a toe.
This is made of wood.
Just to acknowledge that people
have probably tried to use the
materials that were in the world
around them to replace parts of
the body that were lost to
trauma or disease for thousands
of years.
We've gotten quite good at it
in some senses,
but there are still significant
problems left to solve.
The other slide,
here, I wanted to show you what
I think is a remarkable
material.
This clear part here is a lens
that's actually implanted into
the eye.
It's like a contact lens but
it's permanently placed inside
the eye over your natural lens.
This is for people that have
very severe difficulty in
vision, because the properties
of their natural lens have
changed.
So, you can put an artificial
material, so it's made of a
polymer, inside the eye.
It can stay there for the rest
of their lives restoring their
vision to near normal and
requiring no other effort on
their part.
They don't have to put in the
contact lens everyday,
because it's there inside their
eye all the time.
What kinds of materials are
these that we can use now to
replace or restore the function
of tissues that are damaged?
Well, many of the materials
that are used,
most commonly,
and with the most success now
are polymers or plastics.
We've talked about some
different aspects of polymers
and medicine throughout the
course here.
What I wanted to show you on
this slide is--and again not
that you would memorize or even
be able to read all the details
here,
but there are a large number of
different synthetic materials
that now are produced and
regularly used in medical
applications.
Polymers,
as you know,
are manufactured products.
Most of them are made from
products that are derived from
petroleum or oil.
They're organic molecules,
typically small units that are
polymerized together to form
long chains.
Because the individual
molecules in a polymer are long
chains, when you put a bunch of
them together in a material,
they entangle together and they
give you a nice material
property.
You're not falling down to the
ground now because the plastic
chairs that you're sitting on
are quite strong.
This polymer material that
makes up the base of the chair
is able to support your weight,
and does it very reliably for a
long period of time.
You also notice that these
chairs, if they were made out of
wood they would be very heavy.
These are quite light,
you can pick them up easily.
If they were made out of metal
they would be much heavier,
they might be stronger but they
would be much heavier.
One of the advantages of
polymer materials is that you
can make things that have quite
a lot of strength but are still
fairly light.
That's one of the advantages of
polymer materials.
You can also change
properties of the polymers.
That's one of the things that
engineers have learned how to do
with quite a large degree of
sophistication over the last 100
years or so.
You can make many different
kinds of polymers,
now, that differ in the
chemistry of the monomers that
are linked together to make
these long chains.
You can, of course,
change the length of the chain.
You can make materials that are
made up of polymers that have
very long chains or shorter
chains.
As you could imagine,
that changes properties,
like the material property of
elasticity that we talked about
a few weeks ago.
We've discovered,
mainly through a process of
trial and error,
that many of these materials
are biocompatible.
That is, you can put them in
contact with tissues of the
body, and the side effects of
implanting that material are not
severe.
Now, in a few slides I'm going
to tell you more about how the
body responds to biomaterials.
What you'll see is that the
response can be very mild to
some materials that inert,
and can be quite vigorous to
materials that aren't so inert.
One needs to select a material
that's appropriate for the
application that you want to use
it for,
has the right properties for
the application,
and also has the right extent
of compatibility in the tissue
you want to use it in.
This is just to show you kind
of the range of materials that
can be used now in some of the
applications in which they're
used.
We'll talk about that as we go
through the lecture today.
One of the applications
I've already talked about last
week was making tubes of
polymers,
tubes of polymers that can be
used to replace the conduits
through which blood flow.
This slide shows you some
examples of arterial grafts,
so synthetic materials that are
used to replace a segment,
let's say of the aorta.
This might be needed because
the patient has had some kind of
trauma where their aorta has
become ruptured like in a car
accident, for example.
It's deep within your body so
it would have to be a pretty
significant trauma in order to
hurt your aorta.
More commonly,
sometimes there are diseases of
the aorta where the wall of the
aorta becomes weak and causes
what's called an aneurism,
or a weak spot in the artery
that can balloon out.
Obviously, if that becomes so
weak that it bursts that's a
medical emergency.
If you diagnose those early
enough then you can replace that
segment of the aorta with a
synthetic polymer.
This has been done for decades
now, there are several different
materials that can be used in
this way.
Because the aorta is a large
caliber vessel it stays patent,
that is the blood can flow
through continuously for many
decades.
This is true for vessels that
are larger than say 5 mm in
diameter.
As the size goes down,
it becomes more difficult to
use synthetic materials in these
applications.
You can't use a synthetic
material like this in the
coronary arteries,
for example,
of the heart.
We talked about that several
weeks ago.
I'll show you some pictures
that show you why that wouldn't
work in smaller diameter vessels
in a few moments.
Most of the materials that
are used here were initially
developed for other purposes.
The two most common materials
that are used in conduits like
this are Dacron,
which is a synthetic polymer
that was first--was used for
lots of things but it's made
into clothing,
for example.
Surgeons like it because it has
nice properties,
you can sew it easily.
Imagine that a material that's
going to be used in an
application like this,
a surgeon has to be able to sew
into it fairly readily.
It has to be able to hold a
suture, and that suture line has
to make a neat connection or
anastomosis with the native
vessel.
Surgeons being able to sew into
the material reliably is,
obviously, an important part of
the design.
Dacron, a textile,
has a nice property that way.
The other material that's
used often is a material you're
familiar with called GORE-TEX.
GORE-TEX is basically Teflon,
its Teflon that is treated in a
special so that it becomes
porous.
One of the properties of
Teflon, you use it as cookware,
for example,
because things don't stick to
it.
It's not a sticky polymer,
it's fairly inert to
particularly proteins that might
stick on the surface.
On it's own,
it would not be porous and so
it wouldn't allow any molecules
to pass through.
GORE-TEX, on the other hand,
is fashioned--and this is a
picture of GORE-TEX at very high
magnification here,
so it has small pores in it.
Pores that are so small that a
droplet of water can't pass
through, but molecules of water
can.
That's why GORE-TEX is so
useful as a material for hiking
for rain gear,
it allows water to evaporate
through it but doesn't allow
drops of water to go in.
You can make a waterproof
material that still allows your
body to sweat and for vapors to
come off your body but doesn't
allow water to go in.
That same property makes it
useful for arterial grafts as
well.
There's some facts on this
slide that show you how many of
these operations that use these
kinds of materials are performed
every year.
Another example of using
synthetic materials like that is
in the heart valve.
We talked about how heart
valves function several weeks
ago.
We talked about how your heart
becomes very inefficient in its
pumping action if the valves
don't work properly.
There are diseases of valves
that are not uncommon.
Many people,
decades ago,
died because--at relatively
young ages because their heart
valves would stop working.
Their heart,
even though it was beating
properly, could not deliver the
flow rate that was needed to
sustain life.
Here's an early example of a
mechanical valve,
a totally synthetic material
that could be used to replace a
heart valve.
Now, this is a collar here,
which is made of a textile that
can be sewn into the spot,
to the ring of tissue where the
heart valve goes.
You can see that white material
there, there's a metal ring
underneath it and on both sides
of this ring there's a cage,
a small cage on the bottom and
a larger cage on the top.
The heart would be down here,
the ventricle would be down
below this here.
If there was pressure on this
side, it would force the ball
up.
When the pressure in the left
ventricle got to be higher than
the aorta, it would force the
ball up.
Then, flow would go out because
the ball sitting in this
position completely seals the
opening.
When the pressure pushes
the ball up then it opens up a
pathway around it,
so blood can come out through
the sides and the ball goes up
but it doesn't go away because
it's constrained by this cage on
the top.
Now, when the pressure here
gets higher than the pressure
down here, the ball falls back
down and it reseals.
So, it does exactly what we
wanted or what we described the
heart valve is doing,
that is opening up when the
pressure difference was right,
when the pressure was higher in
the ventricle then the aorta,
and then closing again when the
pressure in the aorta was higher
than the ventricle.
Now, the problem with this
is you remember how the normal
valve opens, it opens like a
doorway.
The normal valve opens like a
doorway, so the part that's shut
totally opens.
There's a very clear path for
flow.
In this kind of a ball valve,
the ball is still in the way.
The fluid has to go around the
ball in order to eject into the
aorta, for example,
if this was an aortic valve.
Because it has to go around it,
there's an obstacle to blood
flow creates an additional
resistance.
Your heart has to work harder
in order to overcome the
resistance of the flow going
around this large ball that's in
the center.
It works well as a valve
but it's not a very efficient
valve, in that it requires your
heart to work more to get a
certain flow rate because it's
blocking--this ball is blocking
the center of the flow.
In addition,
you can imagine this ball
slamming up and then slamming
back down.
Up and down,
could cause mechanical damage
to the blood and it does.
Blood consists not just of
water and molecules but cells,
like red blood cells,
and these cells are sensitive
to mechanical forces.
Everytime this valve opens and
closes it breaks a certain
number of blood cells.
That's also something that you
can live with but isn't perfect.
The most--a better design
was made in, I think about the
1970s, it's this valve that's
shown here.
In many ways it's similar,
it has the same kind of a
textile ring and metal on the
outside.
Now it's shown sort of end-on,
so you're looking through the
valve and what you don't see
here are two,
what are called leaflets.
These are made of metal and
they fold like this,
close like this and then they
open like that.
It's more like a swinging door
and also responds to pressure
because it can only open one
way.
It goes like this;
it won't go like that,
so it only opens in one
direction in response to a
pressure drop and then it closes
in the other way.
This is now the most commonly
used design for a totally
synthetic valve.
Still, a popular valve
that's used are these two valves
that are shown here.
This is one is from a cow,
this one is from a pig,
and they're natural valves that
are recovered from the animals.
Then, they're treated,
they're cross-linked with a
chemical so that they become
permanent structures,
non-living structures now.
These sort of bio-synthetic
valves, what's called in the
caption here,
a bio-prosthesis.
Prosthesis just means
replacement, so this is derived
from natural tissue is an
alternative to this mechanical
valve.
Physicians will use one of
these types of valves or another
depending on which of your
valves needs replacement,
what their own experience is
with people that have diseases
like the ones they're treating.
There are at least several
options available.
One of the problems when
you put any synthetic material,
or any material other than your
own tissues,
in contact with blood is that
you will start a process called
coagulation or blood clotting.
Of course, this natural
reaction is important to our
lives.
If you damage a blood vessel,
the blood vessel becomes
ruptured.
All of a sudden,
the blood is exposed to a
surface it's not used to seeing.
You damage a blood vessel and
instead of the blood flowing
through a nice tube that has a
very consistent endothelial cell
lining,
it's now exposed to the tissue
outside when the blood vessel
gets ruptured.
When it's exposed to the tissue
outside, a series of chemical
reactions gets initiated.
That series of chemical
reactions is called the
coagulation cascade.
It involves proteins that are
also enzymes that go from an
inactive state to an active
state.
This is described in the book
in some detail.
I'm not going to ask you
questions about the molecular
details of this.
I want you to just sort of
understand the concept,
that a protein in the blood
gets activated by exposure to a
foreign surface.
It creates an activated enzyme,
which then activates another
enzyme, which activates another
enzyme on through this network.
The final result is that a
molecule in your blood,
called fibrinogen,
it's converted in to a
cross-linked network called
fibrin.
Exposure to a foreign surface
sets off a series of chemical
reactions.
The end result is that a
natural protein in your blood
that's normally dissolved and
just flowing around in your
blood called fibrinogen gets
cross-linked into a gel or
semi-solid material.
This is the formation of a clot.
Now, when this reaction
happens, this cross-linking of
fibrinogen into fibrin happens,
they're usually cells that are
trapped there as well because
these cross-linking reactions
occur in blood and there's lots
of blood that gets cross-linked
into this network.
You form a semi-solid
structural material that seals
off the area of the blood vessel
that's damaged.
Blood now stays within your
circulatory system,
the bleeding stops.
That seal that gets made is a
chemically cross-linked version
of fibronectin,
and you know it as a blood
clot.
You cut yourself,
you see a clot later,
it looks red because--it looks
red but it's solid.
It looks red because there's
blood cells trapped in it,
red blood cells trapped in it.
It's solid because the basis of
it is this cross-linked network
of proteins.
This happens if you expose
blood;
anytime you expose blood to a
foreign material.
It happens if you put a heart
valve, an artificial heart valve
in the blood pathway,
this clotting reaction will
start to happen.
That's what's shown in this
slide here.
You can't see it too well but
this surface would ordinarily
look smooth.
It doesn't look smooth because
there are proteins coagulated on
the surface here.
These proteins of fibronectin
that are being converted into a
fibrin gel.
There are also specialized
cells that also find these
fibrin networks,
and they spread out to help
form a barrier.
These cells are called
platelets, and you know
platelets are also important in
blood clotting reactions.
One of the problems with
every synthetic material that's
used to replace a component of
your circulatory system,
like a heart valve,
is that you form a thin layer
of clot on the surface.
Now, what you hope is that that
happens within the first few
hours of when the heart valve is
replaced.
Then doesn't happen anymore
because it becomes a sort of
natural biological surface now,
and your body tolerates it.
It requires--this only happens
with certain kinds of materials.
That's one of the criteria for
selecting materials that are
used as heart valves,
is that they have to be able to
support sort of a mild clotting
reaction;
a mild, not a severe,
clotting reaction.
What happens if this clot
keeps forming on the surface?
The clot gets thicker and
thicker on the surface and
eventually, since there's blood
flowing by,
pieces of that clot could be
expelled from--or detached from
the surface of the material.
They would flow into your blood.
If they flowed up into your
brain, for example,
they could clog smaller
arteries inside your brain and
cut off blood flow to that
region.
That process is called embolism.
Embolism is when a small
particle is released into your
bloodstream, and embolism can
cause all sorts of unwanted
effects.
So, a bad heart valve might
give you a stroke in the brain.
This is one kind of
reaction to a biomaterial.
These other two pictures show
you other kinds of reactions.
Here's a material labeled as M
here that's implanted under the
skin.
What you see is that after time
this unusual layer of tissue
forms, this is called a part of
the foreign body reaction.
Your body tries to form a kind
of scar around the material.
I'll show you how that happens
in a cartoon in just a minute.
Materials that are very--that
are not so inert can cause
extensive cellular reactions
like the one I show on the
bottom here.
These dots here are cells from
your inflammatory system.
They're neutrophils and
macrophages that are collecting
at the site of the foreign
material.
The material here was a mesh
and you can see where the fibers
of the mesh are,
where there's clear dots here.
You can see there lots of cells
that are recruited.
If you showed this to an
experienced pathologist he would
say these cells are coming in as
part of the inflammatory
response,
as part of the unwanted
response to this material.
Every material produces a
different reaction when you put
it into the body.
The details of the reaction
depend on the chemistry of the
material, its mechanical
properties,
how its surface is treated,
if the surface is rough or
smooth.
From an engineering
perspective, those are all
things that we can potentially
change.
We can design materials
hopefully that minimize the
response of the body to it.
In general, you can't make the
response go away,
and the response appears to
have some general
characteristics.
There's general ways that your
body responds to all materials
and those general ways are shown
in this cartoon.
In the first few minutes,
seconds, or up to an hour,
when you put a material into
the body it becomes coated with
proteins.
Now, where do these proteins
come from?
If this was a material that we
used in the--in contact with
blood, those proteins probably
came from the blood.
If this was a heart valve,
for example,
then these proteins probably
came from the blood.
If you looked at the proteins,
they'd be primarily the
abundant proteins that are
naturally abundant in blood like
albumin and fibrinogen,
other kinds of proteins like
that.
Protein absorption happens very
quickly.
Within the next few days
cells will start to accumulate
around the material.
It appears that--what we know
now suggests that these cells
are recruited to the material
because of the proteins that are
absorbed.
You can understand that--you
know that proteins are--surround
all the cells in our body.
We talked about extracellular
matrix and how there are
concentrated gels or proteins
that surround almost every cell.
Cells like to stick to protein
layers.
If you have a material that's
coated with a protein cells will
stick to it.
Now, the first cells that
arrive and that stick are cells
of the inflammatory response.
In the inflammatory responses,
the natural process of your
body responding to some
potentially harmful event,
these cells are moving around
in your body all the time.
They flow through your
bloodstream;
they crawl through your
tissues, they're looking for
something potentially bad to
happen.
Then when it does,
they try to start the healing
process.
These cells recognize that
proteins are attached to the
material and they begin to
accumulate at this site here.
The first cells that arrive are
neutrophils, the second set are
macrophages.
Now, those are the cells
that I show accumulating at high
concentration around this
material here.
What they do is they start the
healing process and they do that
in a variety of ways.
One is that they release
enzymes that try to digest
whatever is around.
They also send out signals to
recruit other kinds of cells to
come in.
That's what's shown in this
second stage here,
is that the cells condense into
a layer.
They form what are called giant
cells, which are basically
macrophages that fuse together
to form a giant cell,
which in some circumstances can
completely encapsulate this
material.
They send out signals to the
rest of your body that say,
'Something's going on here,
we need your help in healing
whatever is happening at this
local site.
' If this was a splinter,
for example,
that you got underneath your
skin your body's response to it
would be to form a scar all the
way around it and to try to
digest it.
If you've ever had a splinter
that you couldn't get out you
might have waited for a few
days, or a few weeks.
Eventually, the splinter gets
covered with some kind of a
tissue and it comes up towards
the top of your skin and
eventually gets ejected from
your body.
That's one kind of a healing
response that's natural.
If that splinter was too deep
it would just get totally
covered with a scar,
scar all around it.
The cells that are in the scar
tissue would be secreting
enzymes and digestive chemicals
inside trying to dissolve the
splinter.
If it was made of wood,
eventually it would dissolve
and it would completely
disappear.
If it's made of a synthetic
polymer that doesn't respond--or
doesn't get digested by those
chemicals what happens is that a
stable scar forms around this
material that never disappears,
but the material is isolated
now from the rest of your body.
Now, I mentioned that different
materials produce different
levels of response like this.
Some of the responses are very
mild in that you get very little
protein absorbed,
you get very few cells
recruited to the site.
You'd get, not a scar,
but maybe a thin layer of
cellular tissue that would form
around the outside.
Some responses are mild and
those are considered
biocompatible,
and some are more vigorous and
those are considered to be not
so compatible.
It happens with almost every
material we know.
Let's talk for a few
minutes about a completely
different kind of application.
Again, this one that I
mentioned a few weeks ago when
we were talking about
biomechanics,
and that is replacement of the
hip.
I just showed you this drawing
here to remind of hip anatomy.
The pelvic bone is here,
which form a girdle at the
level of your waist.
There's a cup inside the pelvic
girdle called the acetabulum.
Into that cup the head of femur
fits in a ball-and-socket joint,
so that your hip has all the
range of movement that we talked
about in class and in section a
few weeks ago.
If there's a disease of this
bone and this needs to be
replaced, then the general
procedure now is to replace not
only the part--this part of the
hip that contains the joint,
the ball, but also to replace
the socket as well.
So, you create a total hip
replacement where you've got a
material that you put into the
socket,
and a material that you put
onto the femur to fit into that
socket.
I showed you this picture
before and this was a--this is a
design of a material like this,
you see a metal cup that serves
as the new acetabulum.
You see a metal ball that is
attached to the femur,
and this ball fits into this
socket.
Now, if you just had metal on
metal and you tried to move that
metal ball inside that socket,
that doesn't work so well.
Metal on metal,
there's some friction between
these two.
If this was a motor and you had
metal on metal,
you'd put oil in between there
to lubricate.
This is not possible in this
situation.
You put something else in there
to lubricate and the something
else is this white material.
It's a layer of polymer,
a thin layer of polymer that
also forms a cup,
fits exactly into this
acetabulum piece.
The ball of the femur,
then, is gliding on this smooth
polymer piece.
These polymer pieces have been
made of a variety of different
materials over the years,
Teflon, and now most of the
pieces now are made of high
density polyethylene.
Bobby?Student:
[inaudible]Professor Mark
Saltzman: Modern hip
replacements,
and I'll show you some new
designs, now typically have a
lifetime of closer to 20 years.
I'll tell you why many of them
have to be replaced after about
10 years, the older designed
ones.
Design has gotten better over
time with these,
and I'll talk about some of the
ways that it's gotten better.
One of the problems is that
this piece here,
this ball of the femur,
this part that's going to
replace the hip has to be very
firmly attached to the rest of
your--to the rest of the bones
of your leg,
to your femur.
If you're standing on one leg,
all the weight of your body is
really being carried by this
piece of material here.
That's why they're made out of
metal because metals are strong
and relatively light,
and you need a strong material.
Plastic wouldn't work in this
setting.
setting because plastic is too
elastic.
Most plastics are too elastic,
whereas metal is stiffer and
can hold your weight.
What you didn't see in that
previous picture is that there's
a long piece here that goes down
into the bone and this long
piece that goes into the bone
allows you to fix the ball of
the femur to the rest of the
femur.
It's fixed because this metal
part down here goes down into
the shaft of your femur,
and then is held there.
It's kind of like a long,
thick nail that goes down into
the length of the bone and what
you hope is that that large
surface area in contact,
metal to bone,
holds the whole piece into
place so that the hip operates
smoothly.
Now, one of the goals of
this would be to create a design
that naturally integrates into
your bone and,
what's called on this,
a 'self-locking mechanism'.
What would a self-locking
mechanism be like?
Well, maybe you'd put holes in
this material like the holes
shown here so that your bone
could grow through it.
As your bone heals around this
implant what if bone could grow
though the material,
then you'd have bone on both
sides sort of locking it in.
That would be the perfect
design, that would be a--not
perfect, but that would be a
good design.
The problem is that's going to
take some time.
You want the person to be
able to stand up and walk,
and move around,
and function in the period
before that happens.
What is usually done is that
another material is used to lock
these materials temporarily in
place.
That material is called bone
cement;
it's a polymer that can be
polymerized when you shine light
on it.
It's not too dissimilar from
the materials that's dentists
use now to fill cavities.
If you had a cavity filled
recently they put some sort of a
material into the cavity and
then they shine a light on it.
They put on the goggles and
they cover up your face and they
shine a light on it.
The polymer that they put into
the cavity polymerizes and forms
a hard surface.
Here, they put the polymer all
around the acetabular cup,
they put the polymer into the
recess that they push the bone
into.
Then, they shine light on it so
that it starts to--so that it
polymerizes and hardens and
forms a very tough material that
fixes this thing in place.
That's called bone cement and
the material is
polymethylmethacrylate.
You can see that this now
involves at least three
different kinds of materials.
There's the metal that's used
to make the implant,
there's the polymer lining
that's used to lubricate the
joint between the two metals,
and there's the other kind of
polymer, the cement that's used
to fix this in place in the--in
contact with your natural bone.
Here's an implant that was
removed from a patient after,
as Bobby mentioned,
after maybe 10 years they found
out that their hip wasn't
working so well anymore.
They were starting to get pain
from their hip joint or they
weren't able to move it through
the whole range of motion that
they had been able to move it
through in years past.
In this particular case,
this joint was removed.
Here's the ball,
here's the acetabular cup,
there's no polymer anymore.
Where did the polymer go?
One of the problems with older
designs of these materials,
particularly when they use
Teflon and not polyethylene,
is that over time as you used
your hip while,
there wasn't much friction
between the metal ball and the
poly--or the Teflon cup,
there was enough friction where
the Teflon would start to wear.
It would start to wear down and
it would get thinner and thinner
over time.
Eventually, as in this case
with this particular patient,
could totally disappear.
If it disappeared then you've
got metal on metal now,
harder to move your hip,
probably causing pain when you
move it as well because the
pieces aren't lubricated as
well.
In addition,
what happens is that when this
metal is moving against the
polymer, it wears down but the
polymer doesn't vanish,
it has to go somewhere.
What most people think is
happening is that tiny particles
of the Teflon or the
polyethylene are being created
locally.
As wear happens,
you're wearing down the
material, you're creating many
small particles of the material
that are released.
Those particles,
then, can start an inflammatory
response.
Your body will start to respond
to these small particles.
That can also cause local
inflammation,
can cause reactions of tissue
which also lead to pain.
This is one of the biggest
problems in design of hips.
One of the reasons they've
gotten better is that people
have gotten better about making
materials that resist this kind
of wear.
That's why they last for 20
years now instead of 10 years as
they did in the past.
There are newer kinds of
materials that people are
beginning to create.
They're new in a variety of
ways.
One of the ways they're new is
that they don't require as much
bone cement any longer.
This acetabular cup for
example, is made of a ceramic
which is very porous and which
sticks to bone more naturally
and more easily than the old
metal cups used too.
Another difference in this
design, is instead of having a
metal head which moves against
the--a metal ball which moves
against the polymer socket,
this one has a ceramic head.
The friction between ceramic
and a polymer is even less then
the friction between a metal and
a polymer.
These are also much lighter,
ceramics are lighter,
they're very strong.
You can create a joint that
lasts even longer with materials
like this.
Engineers are continuously
making improvements in the
materials that go into joints
like this.
They're making improvements in
the design to make them easier
for surgeons to implant.
Now, a total hip replacement,
putting these pieces into a
patient takes only about an hour
in the operating room,
which is remarkable given the
amount that has to happen during
that time.
I want to quickly review
some other kinds of artificial
materials.
I'm going to talk for just a
minute about something that we
talked about before;
dialysis for kidney failure.
It's an example of what's
called an extracorporeal blood
treatment, meaning that
blood--'extra' means outside,
'corporeal' means body,
'extracorporeal' is outside the
body.
You take the blood outside of
the patient, you pass it through
a device, the treatment device,
and then it goes back into the
patient.
You know, you saw in section
what a Dialyzer unit looks like.
It's an example of a treatment
where blood is passed through
some kind of a device,
something happens to the blood,
something good happens,
and then the blood is returned
to the patient.
A Dialyzer might look like
this, there's blood that comes
into a chamber and that blood
flows through many,
many different hollow fibers.
So, blood flowing through these
fibers.
On the outside of the fibers
you're flowing a second solution
called the dialysate.
Molecules, waste molecules like
urea which are inside the blood
capillaries diffuse out into the
dialysate, they're removed from
the blood.
Blood with a high concentration
of urea comes in this side,
blood with lower urea comes out
this side and goes back to the
patient.
That urea is removed by the
dialysate that goes around the
hollow fibers.
Well, what if you changed
this design slightly and asked
it to do something different?
Instead of just flowing in a
solution of saline or a balanced
salt solution that was designed
to pull urea out of the blood,
what if you put cells in the
area around these hollows
fibers?
What if you put cells in?
What if they were cells from
the pancreas,
for example?
Now, blood is flowing through
this hollow fiber just like
before.
On the outside there's not just
a solution of salt,
but there are cells from the
pancreas.
What if this membrane worked
the same way it does in
dialysis?
It allows for small molecule
weight molecules to go through.
Then, if blood came in and it
had sugar in it,
that sugar would diffuse out
into the fluid in the shell,
what we used to call dialysate.
If blood sugar is high and
these are cells from the
pancreas, what do cells of the
pancreas do when they see high
concentrations of blood sugar?
They secrete insulin.
That insulin would be secreted
and it would flow back through
the tube into the blood.
You could make potentially an
artificial pancreas this way,
that was used to treat blood
outside the body.
A diabetic patient,
blood comes out,
it goes through this device.
Glucose would stimulate the
cells to secrete insulin,
the insulin would go back into
the blood, and the insulin would
be returned to the body.
If these pancreas cells worked
properly, they would respond
just like a normal pancreas
does: when sugar goes up,
insulin goes up,
sugar goes down,
insulin goes down.
It does that automatically
because the cells are responding
to the glucose.
That would be very
inconvenient;
it might be a good solution but
it would be inconvenient if
you're--had diabetes and you
needed this all the time to be
taking the blood out of the body
and you'd have this device that
you'd have to carry around with
you.
What if you made it so you
could implant it totally inside
the body as well?
That's what this diagram shows
here.
Here's an example of that
dialysis unit that is--dialysis
like unit but it's made to be
very small.
You can see the shell,
the outside shell here is a
clear plastic.
It's about the size of--smaller
than a hockey puck but not a lot
smaller than a hockey puck.
There's a tube that comes
in that brings blood in,
there's a tube that comes out
and brings blood out.
This tube goes in and then it
wraps around several times
inside and then it goes back out
and that wrap--those coils of
tubing that around inside are
all surrounded by cells from the
pancreas.
If you hook this up inside the
body such that you have blood
going in one side and then
coming out the other,
then you've created a device
that potentially could treat
diabetes automatically and
continuously,
as long as the cells were alive
inside this shell.
This was in the design of
a--what's called a bio-hybrid
pancreas.
It's made of synthetic
materials, the kind of materials
we've been talking about,
polymers.
It's filled with live cells
that are harvested from a
pancreas.
Now, because there's a
material that separates the
cells from your body,
unlike in tissue engineering
where we wanted the cells to
integrate into the body,
now there's a material that
separates the cells.
So, I don't have to use cells
that are immunologically matched
with a patient,
they're separated.
In fact, I don't even have to
use human cells.
I could use cells from another
animal, as long as they respond
to sugar and make insulin that
works in the patient.
So, you might be able to use
cells from a pig and create an
artificial pancreas that works
in a person.
These designs were made almost
20 years ago now and they work
fairly well.
There are several problems that
still have not been solved.
One is that the cells don't
live forever.
We know from cell culture the
problem with maintaining cells
outside the body.
Here, you would like cells that
last for a very long period of
time and continue to secrete
insulin.
They don't last for long enough
for this to be an effective
therapy in people yet.
A device that is similar to
that, the same kind of idea,
is used to treat patients that
have severe liver disease.
Now, you might think about an
implantable device like that,
but unlike the pancreas,
a device that replaced the
functions of your liver,
we talked about all the
different functions of your
liver.
To make an artificial device
like that pancreas that provided
all the functions of your liver
would need a lot of liver cells,
and it would have to be pretty
big.
People aren't yet thinking
about an implantable device for
liver.
What they do use it,
though, is for--as a device to
support the function of
patients.
If this a patient who has a
diseased liver,
they're waiting for a liver
transplant,
how can you keep them alive
without a functioning liver,
during the time when they're
waiting for a transplant to
arrive?
What some hospitals are now
using are devices in which pig
liver cells are suspended in a
hollow fiber reactor,
very much like a dialysis unit.
The patient is on something
like dialysis,
but dialysis that not only
removes waste products,
dialysis that provides liver
function as well,
because inside this unit are
liver cells or hepatocytes that
are performing all the functions
that liver inside your body
would perform.
This is another example of an
artificial organ.
An artificial organ that's
used in many thousands of times
around the country everyday is
this unit here called a
heart/lung bypass or
cardiopulmonary bypass machine.
This machine can replace the
function of your lungs and your
heart during an operation.
If surgeons need to operate on
your heart, they can hook you up
to this machine instead.
They can stop your heart,
your own heart and then this
machine will take over the
functions of both your heart and
your lungs.
How does it do that?
It does that because there's a
pump, a mechanical pump.
There's blood being removed
from the body and from the
venous side, this is blood that
needs oxygen.
It's being pumped at the normal
cardiac output through a device
that oxygenates it.
The pumps replace the function
of your heart;
the oxygenater replaces the
function of your lungs.
Blood is pumped through the
oxygenater;
it goes from being oxygen-poor,
carbon dioxide-rich,
to being carbon dioxide-poor,
oxygen-rich and then goes back
into your body.
You can remain on a pump like
this for several hours while the
surgeon does a heart transplant,
replaces your heart,
while the surgeon does a valve
replacement.
While the surgeon replaces a
coronary artery,
for example.
This machine can keep your--can
basically serve as an artificial
heart and lungs during surgery.
Of course,
one of the things that you
would like to do is be able to
do something like this but to
totally replace the function of
the heart and have a--this is
only valuable when you're in the
operating room.
It requires an extensive and
talented team to operate it to
keep you alive.
What has been a goal of
biomedical engineers,
for many decades,
is to design an artificial
heart that could be totally
implanted and could replace the
function of your heart when your
heart begins to fail.
We're not there yet.
There are still problems.
What this slide shows you
is some of the designs that have
been tested over time.
This is an early design,
not of an artificial heart but
of an artificial ventricular
assist device.
This is a device that's
supposed to give your ventricle
an extra boost when it needs it
if you're heart is failing and
your normal cardiac muscle isn't
able to create the force to get
your blood pressure and flow up
high enough.
You can read more about this in
the book.
These two are cartoons that
show you what was called the
Jarvik heart,
the Jarvik-7 heart,
which was implanted in a number
of patients and still used in
some clinical centers around the
world when a patient's own heart
has failed and they're waiting
for a heart transplant.
The surgeons will sometimes
make the decision,
the patients not going to live
without some kind of support for
their heart function.
They'll put an artificial heart
in just to keep them alive
during the period when they're
hopefully waiting for a heart to
come.
This is the most recent of
those.
This is the AbioCor heart.
This made of the same kinds of
materials we've talking about,
made of polymers.
A very smooth reliable pump in
a very small form that can be
hooked up to your normal
vasculature and take over the
function of the heart.
Many of the problems that
have been largely solved up to
this point here is to develop
materials that could be in
continuous contact with blood
and not have the kinds of
clotting or other reactions that
could cause problems if you use
this kind of device in a person.
Those problems have,
not entirely,
but largely been solved.
The major problem with an
artificial heart now is how to
power it.
Producing all this mechanical
energy that's required to pump
blood and keep your blood
pressure high requires energy.
So, all of these hearts have an
external power source with them.
There are cables that come from
inside the patient outside to a
system of batteries that power
the heart.
It's not possible yet to make
that power source small enough
that it could be conveniently
either implanted or worn by the
patient for chronic use.
That's one of the biggest
problems with the design of this
particular artificial organ now.
We'll meet this afternoon
in section, course review and
please come with questions.
As I mentioned,
I'll have some material
prepared to just describe what's
covered--what we've covered in
the last half of the course on
the final.
It's been a pleasure.
Thanks.